hi I'm Deadpool the other jolly guy in a
red suit with a Lapworth sitting on here
to tell you happy holidays and the
spirit of his most festive time of year
I've decided to release my holiday cheer
all over the world
how you ask well you naughty stocking
stuffers brace yourselves because
starting today you're getting not one
not two but twelve glorious days of
Deadpool the twelve days of Deadpool
starts now each day a new site will
debut a tasty treat and on the 25th the
sweetest gift of all a brand new
Deadpool trailer so sit back hold on
your ornaments ghazal Oh a little eggnog
at least that looks like eggnog and
prepare yourself because it's time for
Saint Wade to put the wind in winter
wonderland Deadpool in theaters February
12th
hey youtubers is Charlie so just explain
what's going on with this teaser there's
going to be 12 days of Deadpool content
like little teasers that they're gonna
be dropping til they drop the actual
full big trailer I always get really
excited when people try new marketing
campaigns and 12 days of Deadpool sounds
like the most awesome way to get ready
for Christmas Kwanzaa by despite rolling
in his grave it and Marvel doesn't
really do holiday specials anymore but I
thought this would also be an awesome
video to talk about my top 5 Marvel
holiday comics they don't do it quite as
much as they did in the 90s it was a big
thing in the mid 90s when they did
holiday themed comic books but what's
probably gonna be happening for the next
12 days or so till like the 24th and the
25th is we're gonna mixture of funny
clips like this and funny artwork from
the movie they haven't specified exactly
what it's gonna be but if there is new
footage I'll totally do videos for you
guys just let me know what you want me
to do for Deadpool each day like cuz if
there's gonna be new Clips each day
that's a lot of Deadpool videos to be
making either way it's definitely gonna
make the holidays a lot more fun
typically December has been like the
deadest period for movie marketing ever
but now we have Star Wars we have
Deadpool coming in February Batman V
Superman coming in March and then all
the rest of the regular movies after
that there's also even a Star Trek
beyond trailer that dropped today I'm
totally doing the video for that too so
be sure to subscribe to get it but
here's my top 5 Marvel holiday specials
starting with number 5 x-men a miracle a
few blocks down from 34th Street very
open play on Miracle on 34th Street
featuring the x-men Professor X you know
normal uses cerebro to detect mutants
cerebro ends up detecting Santa Claus
number 4 Nick Fury in downtime this is
kind of funny because Nick Fury ditches
the shield holiday party they actually
they I wrote that into the comic just
kicks around town looking for something
to do then finds a letter from an old
girlfriend telling him to live in the
moment you know like infusing him with
Christmas cheer so think of Nick Fury is
like the Scrooge in this story on the
number three Silver Surfer and hark the
herald as in Herald of Galactus ha ha
you know big funny joke Silver Surfer
happens upon this schoolgirl who does
not believe in the Star of Bethlehem the
story of Jesus he takes her on this
intergalactic journey to actually find
the physical Star of Bethlehem they run
into The Watcher and he tells them all
about it
it's a lot of fun if you're a fan of
Marvel characters encountering religion
especially really scientific characters
like Silver Surfer
on the number two the spirit of the
season Marvel
holiday special this is one of the many
Punisher holiday stories you know
usually he plays Santa Claus and it's
like the naughty or nice joke you've
been naughty so I'm gonna beat the crap
out of you but this time being a
Christmas story he embraces pacifism so
some of you will cry blasphemy and
finally at number one Marvel Christmas
story yes Virginia there is a Santa from
the Marvel holiday special in 2005 so a
little bit more recent but this is the
one that turns Ultron into Santa Claus
so you absolutely have to check it out
now this is a ton of other holiday
Marvel specials like when we're Doctor
Doom gets to be Santa Claus when we're
fing Fang Foom saves Christmas the guy
who wrote Back to the Future even wrote
a holiday special for Marvel titled ant
man's big Christmas where ant-man and
the wasp help out this kid with some
bullies but let me know in the comments
what is your favorite holiday themed
comic book or holiday themed episode of
a comic book show you know cartoon
live-action either one Deadpool kills
Christmas so what's gonna happen next is
as Deadpool is gonna kill the cast of
Star Trek beyond would that be an
awesome promo I don't think paramount
would be down for that but I will do a
trailer video it is the full trailer
Idris Elba is in full blown makeup so
it's gonna be a big WTF to talk about
white guys wait for me to post that you
can click here for my last Deadpool red
band trailer video and you can click
here for my arrow and flash trailers for
the rest of the season thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight
you